Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
I love this voicemail. This is
this is sort of a response to
vaccines. Don't work because Colin Powell died.
This is really nicely done. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Mr and Sir, I have proof
that helmets don't work. There was
somebody who is in a motorcycle accident and
they were wearing a helmet and they still
died. Therefore, we know that helmets don't work
and they're just implementing these helmet laws
in order to divide us as Americans. I think that
you should know that everybody know that is we
got to fight for our freedoms. Thank you, sir.
Speaker 1: Very, very well done, very well done,
and at this point, I mean, listen, we've said
everything that we can say about the death of
Colin Powell from a political and a medical
standpoint. We've covered the weaponization
foaming at the mouth anti-vaxxer ism that has
resulted from the death of Colin Powell. And this
is sort of like a nice, nice, nice cherry on top.
We have such a good bonus show for you today. We
may actually record and archive this one. The NHL
has suspended San Jose Sharks player Evander Kane
for 21 games because he submitted a fake COVID
vaccination card. He forged one and submitted it
is 21 games, even a strict enough punishment. And
was he suspended with or without pay? We will talk
about all of them. We will talk about all of those
details on today's bonus show. Secondly, a right
wing social media influencer and radio host Dan
Bongino is now threatening to quit his radio show
over the company's vaccine mandate.
Now, he also works for Fox News.
He's not said anything about Fox News's vaccine
mandate, which is one of the strictest of any
company we're aware of. We will talk about what's
going on with Bongino. And lastly, right now,
even though globally COVID cases are declining,
even though in the U.S. COVID cases are declining,
the United Kingdom has one of the highest COVID
infection rates in the world. We will talk about
why on today's bonus show, don't miss the
bonus show. Every day we do another show,
it's an extra show. We've got this hour show
that you're watching or listening to right now.
And then we do another show. I'm joined by
producer Pat where we talk about more stories.
You can access the bonus show by becoming a member
at Join Packman dot com. It's easy. It's quick.
It probably takes a minute for someone of average
computer skill. Join Pacman dot com. We have a
discount code. It'll save you money better. 21.
Use it if you want or not, it's your choice,
completely your choice. Not only do you get access
to the bonus show as a member, you also get a
commercial free audio stream of the show daily.
A commercial free video stream of the show daily.
And when we do our viewer town halls, as we did
last night, members get priority. It's almost like
TSA PreCheck for the live town halls. Or I don't
know. You know, we use whatever analogy you want.
A lot of great member benefits. Sign up at join
Pacman dot com. We will see you on the bonus
show in. It'll feel almost like the snap
Unidentified: of a finger to you that.